la Unión Europea Estados Unidos y sus
aliados han impuesto medidas punitivas
contra Rusia desde su invasión a Ucrania
la idea castigar a las Industrias y a
los individuos que participan en la
guerra
estoy firmemente convencido de que estas
sanciones están teniendo consecuencias
muy duras para la economía rusa Europa
Norteamérica Corea y Japón han reducido
considerablemente sus importaciones de
petróleo y gases ruso a pesar de ello la
agencia Internacional de la energía
sugiere que las sanciones apenas han
hecho Mella en la producción rusa de
petróleo que Julio envió 7,4 millones de
barriles al día por debajo de los 8
millones de principios de 2022 20 mil
millones de dólares en ventas mensuales
en lo que va de año muy por encima de la
medida de 2021 de 14.600 millones el oro
negro se ha desviado hacia nuevos
destinos indias ha convertido en un gran
importador China y Turquía también
señala que algunos países del Golfo
incluso están comprando petróleo Rusia a
precio reducido para utilizarlo en casa
mientras venden el suyo a precios de
Mercado el Ministerio de economía de
Moscú estima que los ingresos por
exportaciones de energía aumentarán un
38% en este año los gobiernos
occidentales han tratado de mantener una
línea fina con sus sanciones a las
exportaciones rusas de gas y petróleo
con el objetivo de golpear a la economía
rusa sin causar estragos en los mercados
energéticos mundiales la próxima prueba
para Moscú un nuevo embargo del bloque
europeo sobre el petróleo que entrará en
vigor en diciembre